ça nous arrive allez une autre question
selon vous qui a dit elle ne veut pas
partager la fiche avec un arabe là c'est
grave
je suis content que vous soyez choqué oh
je disais tu sais toi vas-y non moi je
disais Déborah disait je pense aussi oui
Lisa
d'accord
qui est d'ailleurs à l'affiche ah j'aime
bien le bling bling et exactement la
fiche du film le principal qui est sorti
cette semaine au côté de Marina Hans
Yolande Moreau Agnès en pleine promotion
pour le film il est accordé une
interview évidemment dans le journal
Libération du 9 mai dernier mais non
justement on sait pas alors c'est dans
les années 90 visiblement visiblement
d'après les dates ça pourrait être
Sandra Bullock mais c'est pas sûr ah
pourquoi il a tourné
il devait jouer le rôle
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment blessé
c'est vraiment blessé c'est un petit
formidable je disais c'est le plus
grands acteurs il faut quand même le
dire c'est choquant tout de même ça
cette histoire non
c'est pour ça qu'on a envie de savoir
qui c'est qui a eu des années 90 qui
colle aussi c'est le film Belphégor avec
Sophie Marceau ou différent là vous
laissez entendre que c'est Sophie
Marceau
alors moi j'ai regardé aussi les films
des années 90 si tu veux je vois pas
quelle actrice aurait pu refuser ou de
dire cette horreur Bernard c'est un
c'est une actrice qui n'a pas voulu que
le film se fasse avec lui donc peut-être
que c'est pas dans cette photographie
est-ce que il aurait pas été pris aussi
au casting et est-ce que il aurait pas
présupposé que voilà voilà est-ce que ça
a été prononcé cette phrase
si le sort c'est un traumatisme pour lui
il a évoqué dans l'idée il a dû être
profondément choqué et on le comprend et
maintenant son parcours actuel prouve
que c'est un grand acteur et genre je
vous emmerde parce que c'est vraiment un
petit formidable
ne veut pas partager la fiche avec un
arabe c'est ce qu'on lui a dit c'est
quand même important
le cinéma c'est pas un truc pour nous
les enfants d'immigrés c'est ce qu'il a
rajouté par la suite dans ma génération
celle des Jamel Debbouze et Sami
boudjila nous avons pour seule référence
les deux lombes Belmondo Depardieu et le
seul acteur qui nous ressemble c'est
l'ouvrier algérien d'Elise ou la vraie
vie de Michel drive c'était le mari vous
le savez de Marie-José natte mais on
l'envoie jamais dans le film d'ailleurs
voilà c'est important c'est traumatisme
je comprends les discriminations et
Florian il a commencé dans la série
tribunal ou justement et jouer un
maghrébin délinquant etc c'est le
premier rôle voilà donc ça ça corrobore
un peu ce qui dit là et on lui proposait
que des rôles comme ça et c'est vrai que
dans les années 90 il y avait beaucoup
de racisme dans le cinéma aussi parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup moins de
d'acteurs d'actrices d'origine
maghrébine africaine etc donc c'est pas
Benoît et moi ça me rend fou les
discriminations et les quotas on a tous
fait part à un moment justement j'avais
demandé qui a été victime de
discrimination
c'est pourquoi ben je sais pas si je
peux le dire et tout mais au tout début
moi je dis ce que tu veux mais fais
attention tu donnes pas de nom j'ai
commencé dans Secret Story il y a des
années j'ai fait le casting et du coup
il y avait la production de production
qui est en bémol et TF1 diffuseur et
quand on démarre a proposé mon projet
mon profil TF1 a dit non on veut pas
c'est trop une folate il est trop gai à
quel moment on peut dire à quelqu'un il
est trop folle il est trop gay il est
trop lui et donc du coup ils ont créé un
jeu avant sur un template en plus il
faut je sais pas d'où ils ont tiré seul
des idées et donc ils ont créé un jeu 72
heures avant sur internet pour que ce
soit le public qui me valide pour pas
qu'ils prennent la responsabilité de
faire rentrer la folasse bon finalement
j'ai gagné
on peut l'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
ensemble
tu as 21 ans en disant tu es trottoirs
là c'est tout TF1 te veux pas et on
démolle dit nous on te va absolument du
coup on va créer ce jeu c'est le public
qui va te sélectionner genre
je sais pas comment leur est venu cette
idée à ton propos ben non mais moi je
cherche
[Rires]
moi un peu avec ma couleur de peau ça a
été compliqué parfois j'ai su après des
entretiens d'embauche que ça convenait
pas spécialement et puis surtout à
l'époque où quand j'avais 18 20 ans etc
pour rentrer en boîte c'était beaucoup
plus compliqué on a fait quelques petits
tests avec des amis etc et pour moi
c'était à l'époque un peu plus compliqué
ces années 90 aussi c'était avec c'est
dingue mais moi je veux dire au début de
ma carrière en 85 à la télé moi j'étais
à Bordeaux d'abord et après je suis
arrivé à Paris en 87 à TF1 mon cher
Laurent on nous dit étions la figure-toi
que déjà on me disait non non l'accent
bordelais là ça va pas du tout les
accents c'est une discrimination aussi
mais toujours mais je l'ai encore quand
je m'énerve il paraît honnêtement je
crois qu'on a tous un truc qui nous
regardez j'étais frisé comme un mouton
je martyrise mes cheveux
là haut ah
rigoler mais c'est à cause que j'ai dit
ça fait tomber ça va échappé oh là là
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel le choqué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors Isa j'avais été sûr si vous la
lancée Isa on est foutue alors que
Florian c'est l'inverse
de sujet je sens que là ça commence à
déraper c'est trop tôt les amis c'est
trop tôt